one word to describe the season
confusing why because people's behaviour
confused me everyday I've never been
around a group of women when there's so
much drama hey guys this is housewives
happy hour I'm Bryce sander and we've
got two new Real Housewives of Dallas
here DeAndre and Cameron you guys ready
for this yeah well let's cheers to you
joining the family the roller coaster
why did you want to do the show I just
wanted to go and hang out with a Nico
and in the clubhouse I mean hello who
doesn't wanna hang out Andy Cohen but
should be honest I just wanted to spin
in a beautiful gown priority line
exactly a line you know dumb blondes get
noticed
smart blondes get everything camera goes
oh girl it'll be so much fun
I said Cameron no this is not gonna be
fun it's not the word you want to say
I'm starting to get my pissed
there's a couple people on the show that
can mow you down in like yeah 15 seconds
I have these crazy memories and I'm like
wait you were paying attention I was
drinking my champagne where do you guys
fit in
who are you aligned with and does that
change I think you'll probably see our
all our friendships evolving throughout
the show and I think I'm friends with
everyone
[Applause]
see who's really honest if is a
backstabbing [ __ ] who's the biggest
ester of the group this season how you
told me [ __ ] oh you're gonna do it yeah
people's behaviour confused me everyday
I mean we'll be hanging out and
something will happen I'm like what and
we really just happened like we were
just like red I mean it's just the
craziest thing I mean I've never been
around a group of women when there's so
much drama you know my regular a friend
group doesn't have as much drama so this
is like a new experience who do you
think is going to have the toughest
season this year no I mean bigger the
personality the bigger the problem yes
we'll end on that note
welcome to the roller-coaster night yeah
thank you for having us right yo
[Music]
[Applause]